foreign
[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to tomes of
Terror and this is going to be the first
one of uh several kind of Halloween
related books that I'm doing leading up
to uh you know the big day which is my
favorite holiday of the year obviously
as most of you guys know if you've been
here for any length of time so today the
one we're talking about
uh the author CB Hunt is actually the
owner of grindhouse press and from what
I could determine this is the first one
of uh book of hers that I've read she's
kind of like known primarily for Bizarro
fiction and I looked up she has like
some great
the titles of these some of her former
novellas are like so great uh one of
them is called [ __ ] block and I was like
okay I I gotta read that one uh one call
one is called how to kill yourself and
there's also one called Baby hater which
is about uh from you know the synopsis
it's apparently about an infertile woman
who becomes a baby punching vigilante uh
and reading that I was like yeah that's
definitely a mom on my must read that
shot right to the top of the list I mean
that sounds amazing but yeah so I'll get
around to that uh however the one we're
going to be talking about today is her
2019 Novella Halloween fiend which
obviously is one that I wanted to kind
of dig into right around the lead up to
Halloween obviously uh now this one is a
little less out there conceptually like
it's not it doesn't have a baby punching
vigilante sadly but it's kind of cool
because it's sort of like a very
Halloweeny like almost folk horrory uh
monster story kind of take on Shirley
Jack toxins classic short story The
Lottery which I'm sure most of you at
least in the United States
um I don't know if they still do but we
read it in school and I kind of feel
like a lot of people know it from that
so it's pretty short it's only about 110
112 Pages something like that but the
vibe of it really got me into the whole
like October frame of mind now I will
say though that even though it is very
Halloween forward
um I'm not sure I'd call it like
particularly fun or funny like it's not
like a horror comedy or it's not like
spooky kind of like fun Halloween it's
kind of more like gloomy and sort of
grim and it also has a main character
who's very fatalistic and like kind of
passive and they and it makes him like a
little bit hard to root for at least at
first so just know that going in if you
want something that's kind of more fun
or like comedic in tone
um this is probably not it this one's
like not really all that funny so the
story is actually set in a relatively
modern but a time period I couldn't
really determine like nobody seems to
have computers or cell phones for
example but people do seem to have
landlines so so I was thinking 80s but I
it doesn't really matter like in the
course of the story
so it said in this really small Burg
called Strang as in strange without the
e
um only about I think it said only about
100 people like are left in town so like
residents if they die for example or if
they move away which nobody really seems
to
um then their houses just stay abandoned
that's just how it works now there are a
couple of essential businesses in the
little downtown area like there's a
grocery store there's a bar there's a
diner but all of these are very sparsely
patronized because like I said there's
only 100 people and you know they just
wander in and out so usually there's not
a lot of people like wandering around in
the town or anything like that so it's
never made particularly clear how long
the curse that hovers over this town has
been going on
but it's apparently been going on long
enough for you know the few dozen
residents remaining to have become very
complacent about it and it's just kind
of like oh well this is our lot in life
and this just is what we have to do we
don't really like it but you know
they've just kind of like resigned
themselves to it
so basically what the curse entails is
that there's like a shape-shifting
creature
that terrorizes the town every night and
because of its habit of kind of going
around reciting sort of Halloween
adjacent phrases and Rhymes Like
trick-or-treat timer Rhymes or other
ones that are kind of like Halloween
related the townsfolk just call it
Halloween that's what they call it now
most people just see it as kind of like
an Ever shifting ever moving blur like
you can't really get a good beat on what
it looks like but sometimes uh every now
and then like someone will catch a
glimpse of what seems to be its true
form which I won't spoil but it's just
kind of like I mean the way it's
described is like really really cool but
most people just kind of see it as like
something like that you know what I mean
so every night every household uh must
put out a treat for Halloween and this
is in the form of a small animal which
the creature uh subsequently devours so
yeah if you're sensitive to hearing
about guinea pigs and the occasional cat
getting eaten by monster then you know
just fair warning go again because a lot
of that happens in this uh you know
every night you got to put an animal out
for it uh this is done presumably to
keep Halloween from feeding on any of
the humans in town
however though once a year on Halloween
All Hallows Eve the town officials and
Strang put on this big fall festival and
it's funny because they are all very
like kind of fake cheerful about it like
ooh the Fall Festival but then they kind
of make it like low-key known that it's
like you have to go you know what I mean
like it's compulsory
so you know the the festival has
everything that a fall festival you
would think has it has like games and
hay rides and food trucks and all that
kind of stuff however at the end of the
night after the fun is over somebody
gets the dot meaning that they get
essentially randomly chosen to be
sacrificed to Halloween and this is what
I meant when this is kind of like a tip
of the hat to Shirley Jackson's the
lottery because you know that's I feel
like everybody's read that story but if
you haven't that's kind of what that is
you get a DOT on a piece of paper and
that means uh you get stoned to death
now this annual ritual has been going on
just pretty much for as long as anyone
can remember because at this point like
I said not that many people get to move
out so there's like generations of
people that have grown up with it so the
character through which we see this
story unfolding is this kind of like
overweight middle-aged kind of dude uh
named Barry Johnson now his mother was
actually taken by Halloween when he was
just a kid which was unusual usually
Halloween they like they have a deal
with Halloween like as long as they put
the animals out and then they give them
a person once a year like he doesn't
usually like pick off people at random
at other times of the year but for
various reasons like his mom got taken
when he was just a kid and ever since
then
he's lived in his childhood home with
his aging father who's kind of like this
cranky old coot who's confined to a
wheelchair
um and he's kind of one of those guys
that it's like he like shuts off his
oxygen tank so he can chain smoke you
know what I mean and Barry's like afraid
he's gonna blow the house up one day
it's that kind of dude uh so Barry kind
of works this dead-end job at the only
grocery store in town and also sort of
low-key has a crush on this woman named
Rhonda who works as a waitress over at
the diner but he's like way too timid to
ever do anything about it like he never
asks her out or anything like that so
he's kind of been going through the
motions of this depressing life that he
has I mean he works at a job he hates he
hates his co-workers he cares for his
dad who just incessantly complains and
berates him and he has to raise this
seemingly endless stream of guinea pigs
like to feed to Halloween every night so
that Halloween doesn't go on a rampage
he's also as The Story Goes On like
becoming more and more convinced that
Halloween is taunting him specifically
for reasons that he can't really begin
to Fathom the day of the Fall Festival
is fast approaching though and Barry is
kind of dreading through like going
through this whole ordeal again
everybody does because they know that at
least one person is going to get the dot
but you know it's it's just kind of
leading up to that this year though a
few things turn out differently than
usual
for one thing and I'm not going to spoil
all the things that happen but for one
thing the Town Council decides to bring
in an outside company to set up some
rides at the festival like they never
had rides at the festival before
um and obviously nobody in town knows
how to like set up carnival rides so
they had to like bring in an outside uh
you know an outside company to do it and
that means that there's going to be a
handful of strangers in the town for the
first time in ages and ages now
everybody in town kind of knows the
rules no one is supposed to tell
Outsiders about what's going on in the
town like even if they talk to their
friends or relatives like outside of the
town like on the phone or whatever like
you're that's just kind of like an
understood thing that no one's supposed
to tell anybody about Halloween or what
goes on there but uh in this case things
end up getting a little more complicated
when Barry is cajoled for various
reasons into housing two of the carnies
uh that come there to set up the rides
and that's kind of like the inciting
incident that you know leads to the
conclusion leads to the climax so I mean
this was just a very very short suitably
spooky but like I said more on the Grim
depressing end not like the fun ookie
spooky end
um but it is like very entertaining
slice of Halloween goodness you know
what I mean if you want something to get
in the mood because it's so brief uh
there isn't a hell of a lot of character
development especially of kind of like a
lot of the peripheral characters and
there also isn't much backstory given to
um the history of the town or why
Halloween stalks this place specifically
uh most of the story is actually kind of
like the setup like explaining like the
deal and everything I mean you are
seeing things through Barry's character
like through the whole time but a lot of
it is just kind of like explaining you
know what's going on like why things are
the way they are
um so it actually in that way it kind of
reads a little bit more like a fable
and like not too much I don't want to go
too far in that direction but it is very
a little bit fable-like and it actually
does seem to be satirizing at least to a
degree and I could just be totally
reading this into it um so you know
forgive me but it seems that it's kind
of satirizing the extent to which
people can eventually become like
compliant and maybe like apathetic
towards any circumstance even like a
really horrific one like the one that
these townspeople are experiencing now
as I mentioned the main character Barry
isn't terribly sympathetic because he's
just very brooding and resigned but
that's kind of like the point of the
story though like I said I think that's
at least kind of how I read it and he
does get a little bit more proactive
like as The Story Goes On so you do kind
of start to root for them as [ __ ] starts
to get worse and worse
um now I will say just as a little
nitpick there are there were some like
grammatical errors in there like a
couple instances with differences
between their th uh eir like being
confused with t-h-e-y apostrophe Ari
like not not many I've played like I've
read some that were like way worse than
that but this could have gone like a
little bit more like fine-tooth comb in
with like a with an editor because there
were like a few grammatical errors but
not so many that it really like
distracted me all that much but I did
notice it so I will point it out
um but overall I'm gonna say like if
you're you're looking for just like very
succinct little shot in the arm of
Halloween fun uh typical like I said
it's not super fun but like just
Halloween story uh to put you in the
mood for the season then uh you know
this one is absolutely worth reading and
I actually really enjoyed it quite a bit
so that'll do it for this tomes of
Terror I will see you guys again for
another Halloween book on the next one
bye